just an fy for people who don't know who
desantis is here's his background i
don't think a lot of people know this
governor desantis graduated with honors
from yale university by the way this is
not one of those things that some people
say that they graduate honors and then
you realize they're at the bottom of the
class this guy should graduate with
honors at the top of his class we know
another person who claims that captain
of yale's varsity baseball team as a
senior in 2001 he had the team's best
banning average at 336 graduated with
honors from harvard law school
as if yale is not enough while at
harvard earned a commission in the u.s
navy as a jag officer supported
operations at the terrorist detention
center of guantanamo bay
after active duty served as federal
prosecutor where he uh targeted and
convicted child predators he still
serves in the u.s navy reserve and casey
desantis his wife is an emmy
award-winning television host and
desantis spent a year as a history
teacher at darlington school what else
does this man do i mean is this what
else does he do i mean yeah obviously
his background is incredibly impressive
he's an impressive leader and i think
his background shows that and i think
what we see in florida and his
accomplishments it proves that but you
know this whole idea of like a
competition between him and term how
would they be competing i mean
president trump isn't running for
governor of florida he's he's been
supportive since really since day one
when governor desantis decided to run
and um you know there's no
there's no reason for them to be
competing it's all like i said it's all
kind of like you said people are
speculating about it but that's all it
is it's speculation and it's it's driven
by the media maybe not entirely
maybe it's some people's personal
opinions but you know i can't really
comment on you know how they say 50 of
jokes are true you ever heard that thing
like somebody jokes with you and you're
like wait was that it's funny because
it's true yeah yes my gosh it's true i
think 50 of speculations are also i
think this is one of those speculations
where i think it's comp i mean trump
just said on october 3rd 2021 which is
what a few months ago if i faced him i'd
beat him like i would beat everyone else
i think most people would drop out i
think he would also drop out if i'm the
santis okay
and his resume graduated from yale with
the honors competitive
captain of yale varsity team competitive
as a senior 2001 batting average of 336
competitive graduated with honors at
harvard law school competitive while at
harvard he earns a commission
competitive supported territory comp
everything about this i think he was
also a navy seal he was the commander
for navy seal unit is what he was yeah
some of these things we were unaware of
dude he did this
just yesterday we're sitting where time
were like do you guys know what the and
everybody's like what what are you
talking about he was also i think casted
in the movie mission impossible
speculation on the other half right
but here's the point here's the point
actually
i know competitive people uh uh if i
faced them i'd beat them like i would
beat everyone else i think most people
would drop out i think he would drop out
i think in that moment when that was
said the santa's phone probably just
went ding ding
all these things are coming to them and
the scientists with all these
credentials is not going to sit there
and say what a sweetheart of a guy to
say something like that about me so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]